intro since you really the man I'm just
a guest star on your [ __ ] show good
morning everyone thank you and welcome
to coughing commerce the show that
intends to and our vision is to push the
commerce conversation forward so we're
super excited to have sales forces chief
digital evangelist Valle offshore with
us today Paula well you and I have been
you know real-life friends we've
interacted a couple of times
unbelievable Twitter buddies for a
decade here so why don't you take the
first two minutes take the floor and
tell everybody what that means that of
what you actually do at Salesforce and a
Neiman why don't we even do two or three
minutes on your origin story of how you
got there because I think you know
knowing my audience which is obviously a
high percentage of the people watching
here
I think they'll bring some value it to
the audience and then and then we'll get
into some nitty-gritty of the State of
the Union from Zubin and I in your
perspective absolutely I went to school
and studied Electrical Engineering so I
started my career as a software
developer and an introvert always
fighting impostor syndrome happy to sit
and just write code and but eventually
my career led to running engineering and
the technology firm and then the CEO the
company said I want to bring some
discipline you have an engineering on
the service and support seven house and
this was a five hundred million dollar
annual revenue company and so he asked
me to run services this was in 2003 I
had no idea what a CRM was that no idea
what tools needed to run service so I I
researched I got a few of us and they
found this West Coast company couple of
hundred people at the time called
Salesforce and we brought him into our
company Salesforce help triple the size
of my company when I joined Salesforce
the company was a billion in revenue and
I was the chief marketing officer at the
time and I ended up writing a book about
CRM I end up writing articles I fell in
love with social you're the reason why I
fell in love with social I need to say
that I didn't know that I didn't know
your please I'm it I'm a customer of
Salesforce at Dreamforce in 2011 August
2011
now I joined Twitter in 2011 so at that
time
a couple of hundred followers and a
couple of them on my parents so really I
have no network you send a DM to me on
the first day of dream for say I'm gonna
be at the keynote area I'd like to meet
you
of course how you know it's after I've
got the trust economy I mean I read your
book you know I'm following you on
Twitter
but you have hundreds of thousands of
followers you're a verified account I
have no idea by the way to this day I
have no idea why you had the generosity
I actually remembered our I bunny
meeting I am funny
I remember that event very clearly
because I wasn't on the main stage I was
in a separate room and while I was
prepping I was looking at everybody who
was talking about the event and
literally just being a gracious person
and saying hello I like people
it's the first first life lesson
networking is about giving there was I
had I had shocked your chuckling system
that that a celebrity you thought leader
is just randomly wants to meet me again
I you know I I didn't have a footprint
and so it was just unbelievably
surprising to me so I come and meet you
and you asked me about my origin life
name and I'm like I'm a refugee
immigrant and you say to me it's what I
tell him I was born in Iran there was a
war I had to immediately leave it was a
crisis and the most disruptive thing in
your life whether you do it by choice or
your force is leaving your birth country
and you said listen first of all you
grabbed my arm and then you roll up your
sleeve and you said look at my
goosebumps and then I'm looking at my oh
my god I you connected the name it's
such a visceral way by grabbing my arm
and showing the goosebumps and you said
my family emigrated 1978 from Belarus
and my family was in and a border line
at a border and with military protection
and we had to barter with flour for
bread and that's the permission that we
so it was a bag of bread that savory
thing there but it's slightly different
but you got the genesis of it
Israel in America traded wheat to Russia
yeah to let some Jews out knows it like
you know it's just
nonetheless oh well you know how often I
share your content I mean your masterful
and genuinely connecting I remember you
sense of like a 15-second video to me
years after I remember the video was
like I really like what you share on
social like you know I don't I have your
material around my house that reminds me
about the grind that works the gratitude
the mindset of giving without attracting
it yet give give give seven times before
you make an ask I mean these are like
reason and the key and the key for
everybody watching I know we're going a
little high level you're assuming but I
know you love it it's I love you
Kabbalah cuz you're hearing me cuz not
ask not take not get asked and then the
real key is give give give give give
give give give give give give ask person
doesn't reciprocate and don't worry
about it cuz that's where people people
fake give and then expect and they're
devastated when they don't when they
didn't really give my belief is that
giving is giving sure there's times to
ask but if the person isn't reciprocate
all that giving I did did not require
that person to give back to me I gave
for the sake of giving you know the end
and most people are crucially huge it's
why people don't use their crippled yeah
and most people confuse giving with
manipulating God so many people try to
give to me when they're full of [ __ ]
they're trying to give me something that
I don't want in return for me to give
something they want when I have all the
leverage absolutely and I don't know if
it's because us three immigrants
recognize that the world doesn't owe you
anything
but that sense of entitlement is what
cripples entrepreneurs founders business
leaders especially when you climb the
success ladder although I don't believe
in ladders I think when you help people
you become the ladder but but at the end
of the day this notion of the world
anything if you want something you work
for it but I gotta tell you that I
didn't have that realization until my
forties when I met you in 2011 I was 41
years old so I I don't know if it was my
parents my teachers my managers I had
the silo mentality and that silo
mentality was consume resources protect
those resources and extract as much
value as you can from those resources so
I thought the lifeblood of your success
your company individual was just
capturing now by the way at that time
I'm a chief marketing officer hundreds
of people that work for me I have a
hundred million dollar budget so I was
actually doing a decent job of
collecting but it was the first tweet it
was meeting you it was the book the
articles where I realized a lifeblood is
movement of resources the reason why we
have passion for sharing is because I
spent 40 years learning consuming
knowledge resource knowledge and then
using that to better myself but I didn't
take that extra step of sharing what I
knew and I wouldn't be a chief digital
evangelist at Salesforce the first
evangelist at the company hire if it
wasn't for the love of sharing and I'm
telling you you played and I don't say
it enough I should you played a massive
role in opening my eye in terms of the
goodness of giving and you just did it
so naturally like it's my remember like
it was yesterday
thank you for that Zubin I mean train
yeah
yeah we'll see you next time on where's
the one thing that surprised me about
working at Vayner and about you frankly
and one of the things that I said is the
appreciation people have of you not
people that are just getting started
people that are established people that
are incredibly successful in what they
do like vallah and I think that's kind
of the thing that's really important for
people that look at you as a role model
and so hey what does he do how can I do
it right everybody does it differently
but in terms of the genuinity and giving
giving giving giving and ultimately if
you receive great if not there that's
not a zero now why you did I can
continue exactly you did it you know
it's your good no
I'm just gonna say like you know it's
funny this first time I'm gonna realize
this I'm like ooh this is the insight to
why I don't talk about my nonprofit work
you know like when I do business like I
talk about Billy but I new business I'm
like hey buy this baseball card and you
know I new business but when I'm giving
you know I real so many people give back
in charity to position themselves as a
good person it's a proxy it's a
strategic move they're not given for the
sake of giving they're giving cuz it's
gonna make them look good oh you're a
great person oftentimes hiding something
bad you know so like it just literally
just right now I'm like right this is
the same [ __ ] reason that I don't
that I'll go there occasionally but it's
just not my normal state listen we've
gone very high-level in the first 15
minutes I want to really go I want you
to kind of take control here Zubin you
know sales for such a real player in
this space let's let's go in some
tactics what questions do you have in
mind for Bala yes oh look we we talk
about e-commerce obviously all the time
we talk about omni-channel talk about
all these things that's our area of
expertise that's where we focus and and
we want to do is bring different voices
into the conversation right we're
continually talking about Shopify and
with a great relationship with them the
vol event Salesforce and Salesforce
commerce cloud they have a different
type of client they have different types
of clients frankly and so it's great to
hear from different perspectives right
what we see in the marketplace is that
there is kind of horizontal growth
vertical growth happening in the
marketplace and it's just great for our
audience to be able to hear from experts
like voila in this space about a few
things one content right Gary talks
about content all the time while those
posting a lot of content but voilá
writes a lot of content as well he's got
his own show talk to us about content
and how that is actually impacted your
business at Salesforce and then the
other thing obviously we want to get
into let's say right there let's say
right there let's say right there for a
second yeah content is that you know so
I do research I'm a speaker I'm active
on social and I write I read for mostly
ZDNet because there's a technology
audience they're owned by CBS
Interactive so when I cook when I stop
traveling in the first week
March I decided that I'm gonna write
more you know I log into Twitter before
you know in February and tutor analytics
and it says you know 70 million
impressions every 28 days I've written
65 articles since March I'm writing
three four articles a week and now it's
150 million impressions every 28 days so
people are consuming the content no
question now as far as you know commerce
you know we started doing scenario
planning in late February Salesforce you
know working with you know partners
customers employees partners like
Accenture Deloitte PwC we wanted to
bring some experts in terms of
understanding the impact of pandemic
because we've never in our lifetime have
gone from centralized to distribute a
digital model so this construct is
completely new to all of us and I will
say you know how adopting a beginner's
mind I said is critical because I don't
believe there are experts of tomorrow
it's just there's this new norm next one
is going to be vastly different and for
many reasons so the scenario planning
led to us believing that we could be in
the state for three years 18 months to 3
years short short window 18 long window
3 3 years meaning in absence of things
67 million tests a day in absence of
herd immunity in the absence of
automated contact tracing not manual or
zero and then vaccine your you're gonna
have two more factors that define
discretionary spending at any level
individual to big business prior kovat
discretionary spend had relevance was
that made criteria in terms of how
you've spent your hard-earned dollars in
the climate we are today where you have
a health crisis you have an economic
crisis you have a race crisis and
frankly you have a lack of leadership
crisis at present so there's a trust
deficit that Gary talked about you know
the fine line between manipulating and
and inspiring and that fine line is
defined by your intense your moral
motivation and today right now in this
country people don't trust institutions
they don't trust leaders at the highest
level the leadership is as invisible as
the virus itself right now and that's
why we're one of the worst performing
countries in the world in terms of
combating school in these three years
means companies that can remove friction
no inconvenience always wins
and understanding that the two other
criteria on top of relevance is safety
like I'm a father of three I'm not going
to a movie theater I'm not going to a
mall I'm not going to unless I
understand that the safety measures are
in place you know social distancing
wearing a mask cleaning the environment
so all of this means that in my opinion
we've witnessed probably five years of
social and cultural transformation just
in the last five months five years of
transformation now if you look at US
retail in terms of just ecommerce we
went from about 8 to 15 percent of total
retail commerce being digital and it
took 10 years to get that doubling
effect I would be surprised at the end
calendar 2020 where digital commerce is
30% of total retail so you've looked at
10 years of acceleration of adopting
digital commerce contactless payments
order online pick up curbside you know
all of these measures to ensure safety
and the last thing by the way is is it's
not just safety its accessibility
there's certain businesses that that
can't open frankly and you've seen a lot
of states not going back to phase 1
given the explosive yeah 71,000 positive
cases estimate that was a record
according to dr. fox's you might enter
August with a hundred thousand new cases
today now what that means is that if
you're a business and you're not
investing in commerce you're not
removing friction you're not taking
advantage of the the mindset where
safety and accessibility is now really
driving discretionary spend you're gonna
be out of business now fortunately for
companies like yours and mine
companies like mine folks that are
pioneering you know ecommerce quotes on
the b2b and b2c side and really taking
advantage of innovation like was she
learning that powers that
personalization at scale that's taking
commerce to a level where you don't feel
like they're sold to you that the advice
is like a Netflix recommendation or a
Spotify song it's like yeah I do need
this it's amazing how the science of
understanding and individual embedded in
commerce with the power of community
where word-of-mouth and social can
really Drive I you're going to
Commerce is going to be really a do or
die capability I don't care what size
business I don't care what geography I
don't care what industry
now the sad part is I was talking to a
CEO of a 500 million dollar company
yesterday yesterday and she said I had
to shut off my e-commerce because my
supply chain back-end couldn't keep up
with the demand so we're missing on our
promise and it's affecting our brand and
I'm like I can't
she was so frustrated that she's running
a half a billion dollar company but she
doesn't have the complete view of the
commerce business understanding that if
you don't integrate with your back
office if you don't understand your
persona of your buyers and you're not
adapting like I'm a guy that buys you
know black gray you know blue clothing
so when I come to your commerce side if
you don't have my behavior in the past
and you start showing me yellow red pink
so just understanding male extra-large
and color preference and you sort the
content based on my prior purchase
history you can have to or attitude in
terms of improving shopping cart
abandons and increasing your your
retention and acquisition so again I
felt so bad to the CEO because some
people feel like are tweaking it what
said that's it that's the congressman
you're ready to go and they don't
realize that there's a science to this
and the size is getting more
sophisticated and you're gonna lose
market share if you don't understand
that speed relevance personal malicious
person at scale powered by intelligence
is the only way you can compete in
weight and that's why Amazon's market
share is more than the 10 the Detailers
that compete we combined it combined so
anyway sorry those long answer but now
it's the car look where our spider
we are it's so vital that if you sell
something and you don't spend 80% of
your mental energy to be the best in the
world in your sector on the Commerce
ecommerce side of it you're completely
misunderstanding the moment that we live
in you're misunderstanding you know
because it doesn't go backwards to your
point
whatever one day when the date is a
little clearer
Cobin has done to expand and accelerate
whether it's three years or thirty years
or five years it's clearly something you
have to be completely you know asleep to
think it's not more importantly it's a
hockey stick it's not like we go back to
real life that we all knew on April 16
2021 and then all of a sudden of course
there'll be a decline if you're allowed
to go to the store you're gonna buy
something that you're not buying on a
computer right now but forever
right now I see everybody in the
comments I want to read these please
leave a comment right now on social or
to scream you're in on something you
bought during covent on e-commerce that
you already now know you will never go
back to buying in a store please put
hashtag never going back so I can see
them all hashtag never going back and
then list or link or picture the item
right the item that you have now
switched your behavior forever not when
we you know forever so for every
entrepreneurs watching this isn't like
who I want to add this on for this time
I see so many people oh yeah carry me
this now for this time
no there's not for this time it's
forever no it's forever it is forever my
dad who's fought me so hard like we got
into it argument three years ago cuz he
wanted people to front the shelfs of the
store during the day so it looked
presentable which was hurting us cuz he
only had so much for payroll because we
were not getting packages out as fast as
I wanted and it was a fight it was when
I say fight it was a verbal jousting
that that led to me going into a place
of like look and this is why the
business has declined since I've been
gone like really like hurt feelings
right I was only coming because I love
him and I'm like okay you're gonna lose
market share here you're fighting for a
front that doesn't exist anymore that's
declining 25% a year regardless of what
you do I could [ __ ] show back up in
the store and be there twelve hours a
day and people gonna come and take
selfies with me and buy a bottle of wine
and we're still gonna [ __ ] decline
and now
he literally told Brannon my best friend
who runs the store to last for with me
the whole time and in the penalty for
almost the last 10 years he literally
says things like I don't even give a
[ __ ] it's like he just he's learned like
it's the ship has sailed
I'm trying to convince him to turn the
second floor of the store into a sports
card store I'm not joking
this is their 1996 96% of discretion who
spent go into like seven buckets how to
move where to live what to eat what to
wear how to entertain how to learn how
to heal
96 percent of spam goes into the seven
categories all of these categories are
going to be impacted by commerce because
it is about removing friction and again
companies I keep mentioning Amazon they
spent two billion dollars just to go
from 20 48 hours a 24 hour trying so
you're gonna speed and and and and
personalization are going to be key the
other thing I want to say is that you
know floor thinkers I hear you're Gary's
a futurist because comments you've made
about content and social and digital
marketing where it easily in some
instances a decade ahead and so when I
think about listening to Elon Musk to
talk about this code freeze on
autonomous vehicle today my relationship
in a car when I get in the car is purely
operator 100% of time I'm driving the
car my son is 10 years old when my son
gets his license seven eight years from
now the relationship for him in a car is
not an operator it's an explorer
it's a traveler it's a it's a student
but it gets all their businessperson
natural language processing and voice
enabled digital assistants that are
driving commerce for some of our most
advanced sales force customers mean
you're going to talk to a headless
commerce platform your dashboard and as
you're driving and you're getting close
to Starbucks and that's where you get
your coffee the system is gonna
recommend do you want your Latta your
two miles away you said yes you have
heads-up display you have voice so it's
very safe I'm by the way by the time my
son we're at level four level five
autonomous we can go to sleep and go to
places what people don't realize is that
this is your remote control for your
life your second biggest screen is going
to be your car because the average
is in a commute one-and-a-half hours a
day now that may change because of coma
and you'll be able to work from home
because of the cultural shift this or it
or it will become so pleasant for you to
work in your guest
look the way it looks now I can't wait
right I wish I loved flying across
country in my very comfy lay down
first-class seat working for four hours
nobody bothered me I might just go to a
baseball card store in Ohio five hours
away so I can work in my car for five
hours and enjoy myself I mean people
don't get people don't get it absolutely
and your arms are real quick on this fog
cuz I want to drill this home do you
understand that this is like [ __ ] out
of a [ __ ] sci-fi film for our
grandparents when they were 16 do you
understand that this is [ __ ] Star
Wars [ __ ] and we and this is gonna be a
pager this is gonna look like a pager to
all three of us and everybody watching
in 20 years like a [ __ ] pager this
has 1 million times more the processing
and memory power
so in not quite in my lifetime but in my
father's lifetime all of NASA's
computers what that means is happening
of humanity now has a supercomputer in
her pocket but at the same time in a
recognition I was invited to a UN event
December of last year with Victor and
Sir Tim berners-lee the inventor of the
web and the inventor of tcp/ip protocol
which is the internet and the
celebration for un was in December last
year is the first time we cross the 50%
of humanity accessing the internet right
now one in two of the seventh one seven
billion people in the world so bad wait
wait forget I knew what are you about to
go and I want to just show up in here
people in America you know one of the
reasons one of the reasons I got so
passionate about the åland challenge
when Koba hit was people don't have food
you go to inner cities and and very
low-income areas in this country these
kids their escapism
school and a YMCA they're sitting at
home people are like oh they need to be
homeschooled these kids don't have
[ __ ] Internet
30% of k-12 in the US doesn't have
broadband access so you know it's 12
percent of adults in the u.s. don't have
internet access which was shocking to me
Canada has more Internet access and
mobile access than us so there's a lot
more privilege the fact that we're doing
this right now the fact that you know
we're technologists you have to be
mindful that commit and even prior to go
with there are so many individuals that
just don't have access to technology
like we do and it's folks like yourself
would your generosity and the fact that
you always tried to educate and inspire
people to understand that be grateful
for what you have right now be and give
as much as you can so anyway sorry sorry
sorry no there's absolutely no need for
me to jump in this is fantastic just one
thing to mention so a lot of what you're
talking about right now
like everything you sum it up it's
consumer behavior right technology's
shifting consumer behavior consumer
expectation is shifting people that
don't have access to that technology or
getting left behind
so they need access at that technology
right because as our consume as our
behavior changes then now you look at
the people that are in the audience that
are listening to have online stores they
have their products and retail what do
they need to do the fact the matter is
you need to evolve every single person
that's in the chat is a consumer the the
interesting thing is you talk to a lot
of people that are either selling online
or they're selling in retail whatever
and the the most common-sense things
they don't do because they don't put
themselves in the chair of the consumer
even though there are consumer they buy
other people's products but when it
comes to their products they don't think
about that and you have to balance that
with not creating a focus group of one
right absolutely
so I think so much of my success as I've
navigated around the consumer is I don't
have any beliefs when I have my business
hat on meaning like like I don't want to
make slime but nine-year-old girls do
like by the way what I actually started
talking about sports cards one year
after I decided there was something
there because I
an entire year educating myself and
triple-checking with myself am I trying
to force this to happen because I once
loved it or is this actually just
another observation like social media
the internet you know it was you know
Zubin to your point not only looking at
your own behavior but what so many
people in the chat make a mistake of or
who are gonna watch us or listen to this
later is they impose their points of
view on the world on the market and they
get destroyed my complete neutrality on
it other than what I observe has
completely completely impacted me by the
way
let's get very better I drank nope
alcohol in high school in college cuz I
was completely not into it
yet my first business was a wine
business and I'm one of the most public
figures and social in this 15 year
window and I share nothing about my
personal life nothing had I not been
into this I would not have social media
accounts on the record had I not been a
communications guy a marketing guy a
media guy I would probably not have
social media because I would have
nothing to post because I wouldn't post
my family the way that 95% of people do
and they're like Gary do you know why
you have so much in common with
autonomous vehicles like Tesla because
you know what signals to pay attention
to you get a shitload of noise when we
drive in a car when when I'm sitting
there driving in the car I see the tree
I see this I see the sky whatever the
vehicle drives it knows what signals to
pay attention to not the noise same with
you same with people in the chat like
people tell you [ __ ] all the time but
the key is understanding what signals
matter and which ones do you do
something about yeah and as complicated
as autonomous vehicles are there are
only four building blocks
there's the sensor building block so you
are you're sensing response then there's
the analysis decision and actuation and
the actuation is left right fast slow
it's actually very simple logic but you
put that together when you look at the
text stack of a company like Tesla and
which by the way all future businesses
are going to be built like Tesla the
modularity the ability to sense in
response
it's your humility that you
and the beginner's mind set free of
prejudice really hungry really curious
admit when you're wrong adjust and sense
again market trends that's in your DNA
and that's why I say you're one of the
most prominent futures I've never heard
you call yourself the futures but in my
mind you're a futurist and in this space
I see a lot of folks innovating in this
base becoming Commerce the human mind
for example processes an image sixty
times faster than text so if you've got
Commerce folks thinking about augmented
reality and interactive 3d companies
that are building commerce where you can
take the product like IKEA putting
furniture in your store you take leather
our technology in your iPad you scan
your room and then you place furniture
in your little bit different color
palettes and the exact size and fit
appears you're getting 66% more
engagement you're getting 40% more
conversion you're getting 35% less
returns so one of the statistics that
drive the success of e-commerce is being
accelerated by visual commerce by
machine learning and deep learning in
very simple today simple again sci-fi
five years ago but it really is here now
so advice to entrepreneurs who are
listening and watching two things don't
disqualify yourself if you're gonna
solve an unsolved problem again there
are no experts like I see so many people
worried about are they qualified to do
this thing but it's an unsolved problem
and in the commerce space there's a lot
of opportunities for people to innovate
this and the second thing is state each
about this space is moving really fast
really fast so the most important skill
you can have is you've got a read you
got a right you gotta attend conferences
you got to be active on social if you're
an introvert is difficult for you to
create content engage at least watch and
observe can watch your coffee with
commerce that's another that's an
example of what you should stay
teachable because the world to three
years from now is going to be far
different so hard different in this
space and by the way it's not just
consumer side because I've got adidas
for billion dollars of Congress because
some of that is b2b it so every business
every brand wants to get close to the
consumer you're gonna find this great
awakening on the b2b side that says my
god we need more investment in content
and content because you find that moment
of truth you better have something that
has adds value to your end-user where
there's a business buyer or consumer
speed to value is how you define
relevance and without relevance you
can't achieve growth speak to value
can you cook create value at the speed
of need and you don't get to define the
speed of needs your customer and I'm
telling you digital natives you all
three of us have digital immigrants
people aren't born mobile social in the
cloud my 10 year old is a digital native
all he I mean he knows more about
surfing and connecting than I did when I
was 30 or maybe 40 so you have to
recognize a third of humanity right now
is 18 years or younger the world is
gonna be genset and digital natives and
man if you did you can't connect with
them at the right time on the right
channel to the right person with the
right content to that digital native
world you're a dead business you're a
dead business 52% of Fortune 500 is
disappeared since you have 2000 so don't
think this is like small businesses that
are immune the biggest businesses in the
world half of them have died in the last
in the 21st century every 10 business
day a company falls off that S&P 500
this no one is immune to disruption and
if you ignore Commerce you're a dead
business in my humble opinion so let's
lean into the teachable moments totally
agree
Seth let's drop it some questions we've
got about 10 minutes left let's just
jump into questions from the audience I
so meant to just listen to Gary the
whole time so I apologize this was an
opportunity for the teacher to learn
that to teach her to give to the
students and I just talked too much so I
thought you really didn't because what
was fun for me and why I was saying
unusually quiet myself is you're a very
excited communicator like I am myself
and you're touching on things from a
metal technology standpoint that I often
take for granted because I'm trying to
make it so practical for everybody but
what you did and I was listening and i
was reading the comments what you did is
what i end up you know it's so funny i
always want to go super practical and
then i always get into macro because i'm
like [ __ ] we can't fix this sink
less we fix the well and if I don't get
them to be not insecure anymore
they're never gonna [ __ ] do this [ __ ]
anyway and what I think you did in a
technology way which used to be more of
what I used to do as you know is you're
setting up the framework of like you do
understand this is how I interpreted
what just happened
hey everybody you do understand that
this is hasn't even started and
everything we're actually playing with
right now is minor leagues so if you're
worried about debating even going in on
e-commerce you're gonna wake up in ten
years and get [ __ ] smacked yeah let's
do it ski bum 11:30 it asks how do you
adapt the maintain old-school customers
by by over communicating to old-school
customers about the changes you're
making and maybe even keeping some of
your old tactics just for them we do
this all the time in my companies we
change somebody wants to be
grandfathered in it's less profitable
because we changed but we want to retain
the customer so even though we've gone
full we now communicate on slack we may
have three clients still on gchat or
even though we don't do free shipping
and new jersey anymore with Wine Library
now you gotta buy the library pass
Amazon Prime you know now we still keep
three customers that we did free
shipping in 1999 you're willing to adapt
to keep a little sliver too many people
take the philosophy of the new change
and they burn the ocean with it when all
you needed to do was appease seven
people not scalable but very consumer
centric said I really I really I really
liked that can we clip that I've never
really talked about it that way and it's
actually very clear to me that how much
I do that and how important it is
now take that on a tactical yeah and
good commies good good companies
understand the total lifetime value of a
customer so there's always exception
based and this isn't a light switch this
is a dimmer you know you don't turn off
your you know you got a yeah I always go
to Gary's you know the reason you love
your parents because they loved you
first just get Katoon to give the love
to your good customers be flexible right
now empathy flexibility generosity is
what will define your brand
judging you right now we can use the 37
under other cliche great words that I
love that you love it is blindly
consumer-centric it is blindly cuz there
is no world I live in that any of my
thought process doesn't think why this
is good for them I don't even have the
gear to think about in the micro or the
operations what's in it for me I'm aware
that if I live for what's in it for them
that everything else will turn out okay
one of the number one things I
recognized in the first two meetings I
have a Dubin as he considered to sell
his company to me versus somewhere else
was he had so much knowledge and
communication capability and wants and
needs in him and that I knew one of the
biggest things that I could bring to him
was giving him far more exposure than he
had had I am allocating an ungodly
amount of time to this [ __ ] show
you know coffee and commerce for four to
two reasons number one
Zubin cuz this is kind of what I signed
up for in my mind because I knew it was
important to handlers to you and number
two for the [ __ ] 3,000 people that
are watching right now that instead of
them buying some [ __ ] East ebook for
$4,000 about e-commerce cuz everyone's
coming in that they're getting all this
for free three I know in some way shape
or form that will be good for me whether
that's good for me and grandfather Zubin
telling them this legacy story of Gary
Vee you know or in that you know ginger
beloved in this audience buys you know
from wine texts every day which i think
she does or you know Vicki J in here you
know tell somebody to come to four DS or
Ross press buys you know sports cards
and makes money 10x is money and then
tells everybody that was getting like
and that that's brand to me bring it
transactional or nothing cuz it's just
the right thing to do that's basically
I'm sorry I'm stunned that you knew
names and individuals
knowing that your customer base is
hundreds of thousands of miles we are
I'm reading Tesla I'm reading the chat
that's not the point the point was the
analogy as I used against those
individuals were proper seesee to read
the chat it's different to know what
these people are doing with you
absolutely right Seth what's the next
question so Val VR asks hey guys how
would you go about relaunching an
e-commerce store after being out of
stock for some time because of logistics
delays what strategy would you implement
to get back on top Zubin I'm gonna let
you take over because I've got now a
client slot here because I was taking 50
minutes away so voila
I love you audience I love you subin
take us home we'll talk soon all right
so you out of stock goes back to what
valla was mentioning in terms of a
client earlier we call that he ad with
fortune 500 company look sincerity
authenticity we're talking about that
that's the theme of this entire episode
right so why not continue that with the
actual audience that you have let me
tell you a story
there was a prominent fashion brand that
somewhat of a startup that I purchased
something for from in LA sometime ago
last year anyway
four weeks in no order status six weeks
and I emailed them no email back eight
weeks in oh I'm sorry your product got
delayed and in routing in China or
whatever it was now mind you I bought
this in October so that I could wear it
in November it was like a jacket when we
went to Thanksgiving somewhere so now
it's like December its January they
still haven't responded to me
finally they respond to me and they say
okay look we're sorry we made a mistake
the CEO emails me we're gonna get you
credit etc we're in [ __ ] July right
now and no email still so the point is
like the authenticity of it of being
honest to people you're out of stock why
did you sell it if well did you sell it
to begin with and charge them that's a
different story but if you're out of
stock explain to them what the process
was why do people like going and buying
from empathy wines or something like
when they show you the whole
farm-to-table sourcing path because you
can see the actual path that it took why
not be honest and explain what actually
happened in that entire sourcing
logistics part of the equation and what
you're gonna do to rectify it and why
they should come back so over
communicate and then give them a reason
to come back don't just expect them to
come back and buy from you give them a
credit
the key is LTV the key is customer for
life sorry Bollywood no no it's not much
for me to add to that Trust has to be
your number one core value now you know
recognize people understand that the
pandemic has led to massive supply chain
disruption so you might be surprised if
you through whatever channels you
connect with your customers maybe it's a
newsletter email social you simply state
and admit that you had high demand low
inventory and because of the pandemic
I'm assuming it's because of the
pandemic you the company struggled but
we're back and to show you know to
apologize for the inconvenience you know
there's a there's a there's a promotion
there's some you know give him a reason
to come back but radical transparency at
the end of the day to practice radical
transparency and know that people are
going to be apathetic people are
apathetic of businesses they know
everyone is struggling no one is
expecting perfection but everyone's
expecting high integrity and
trustworthiness I know we keep saying
this on this show I keep mentioning it
but surprise and delight people yeah you
used to go to retail stores you buy a
cologne or perfume whatever they throw a
bunch of samples in there you're like oh
this is awesome I mean if you're not
gonna use them you just love the fact
that you get that exceed expectations
for people this isn't just for those
that have run out of inventory and their
customers are upset but even those that
are actually doing really well surprise
and delight I hate to use another cliche
but this is something Gary's been saying
for a decade he asked a question the
best marketing strategy and his answers
two words care more care more not only
you're going to communicate you have low
inventory but you're going to care more
and do that extra one or two steps to
ensure that
we'll come back and continue to earn you
with their hard-earned dollars you
mentioned something earlier about
personalization and it for the audience
I just want to kind of take that home
and drive at home if you're speaking to
somebody in real life and you sell
shirts for example and you're in the
retail store and they you talk to them
you find out what their style is you get
all this information for them and you go
this is the best shirt for you this is
why you should buy this shirt that's
what we're talking about in terms of
personalization online the somebody
asked earlier in terms of how do I deal
with my old-school customers etc
personalization don't just [ __ ] send
everybody back to the same home page
that has the same product that you're
pushing if you have an older demographic
that you started with and now you're
skewing lower in terms of age well make
sure that you send that older
demographic back to experiences that are
for them no I mean the next time Zubin
walks into the store and you know the
previous experience he you know he
bought that beautiful collar pink shirt
that he's on he has on now if the if the
personal shopper says you know and they
look up in the tablet they don't have to
have a busy memory that's what CRM is
for but they understand your your likes
and dislikes and you see if you have
more collared shirts on sale today I
love an experience when I go back to a
brand and they recognize Who I am and
they understand my preferences that's
how you keep you as a customer
if you treat me like a number and by the
way you know hotels is a perfect example
for those of us who travel you know or
Airlines I don't know how many times I
have to tell them I prefer an aisle seat
and I am a premier member I mean I'm
traveling in a hundred thousand miles a
year and they still don't know my
preferences in terms of where I want to
sit anyway remove friction and that's
how you earn people's trust and don't
over personalize every call I've had
with voilá or most of them he's got a
collared shirt and a tie on so I wore
this to personalize myself for him he
wore this to personalize himself for our
show so don't overpromise
that's exactly right Pushkar a squashy
balled-up what advice would you give to
a technology lover grad student to get a
mind set like yours remember all of this
to me happened in my 40s here 20 years
ahead of me the mistake I made as an
introvert is that I didn't realize
networking was about giving so I I think
resumes are dying so if you're a grad
school you're looking for work the
traditional resume and your updated
LinkedIn profile for most innovative
companies they're looking at your
digital footprint and your digital
exhaust so your brand by the way as a
former CMO people would say what is
brand me your brand is what people say
about you when you're not in the room
now the room is the web and the web are
people and people are more social
therefore the room is more social so
people are gonna learn about you and
talk about you all the time special need
for company now as an individual looking
to build a career your brand is your
digital footprint plus your digital
exhaust so as a student I would say
Google yourself and ask would I hire me
what's the first thing that pops are you
hashtag failing brand
what's that video about you the photo
about you what's the tone and sentiment
about the words you use are you using
remarkable words so companies are using
machine learning powered recruitment
applications to determine your your EQ
not your confidence and the things you
did but the cultural fit for you in a
company to have that mindset knowing
your brand is what people talk about you
when you're not in the room you must
live a recommendable life so when people
are talking about you they're
recommending things about you he's a
nice guy he's trustworthy he's fun to be
around he's smart he's giving are you
living a recommendable life and that
social and digital footprint is really
the web is your resume so the mindset of
giving and caring and knowing that you
will be judged by your presence both
physical and digital and more and more
in the future digital means that you
have to be super mindful
and in terms of how you present
represent yourself live a recommendable
life live it retinas the best advice I
can give and and and start giving giving
means writing giving means podcast if it
means volunteering at community don't
wait for people to tap you on the
shoulder to get engaged get in the game
you can't score on the bench or in the
stands suit up and get in the game and
that's what I didn't do
early in my career but over time I
learned from my mistakes doers will make
mistakes mark doers make original
mistakes so and so learn from it keep
doing keep falling keep getting back up
but live a recommendable life brilliant
alright let's get a couple more
questions in here so Nishant appall asks
hi team gary what do you suggest if i'm
looking to start a fresh ecommerce
business at this time and set something
up while this pandemic is on basically
make money and set up base for future
let me jump in valo
I'll hand it off to you so I got a
couple issues with this question number
one thing is look I agree with you
leverage this opportunity and and when I
say leverage this opportunity what I'm
saying is that there are a lot of
opportunities that you can focus on
right now to build a future for yourself
now what do I have an issue with this
the part about making money right
because when I think about making money
I'm thinking about like a beta or net
income I'm thinking like profit whereas
I think right now the focus should be
not profit I we get hit up all the time
you get hit up by different types of
people that are starting companies
starting d2c brands etc and you look at
their financials and you're like are
their financial projections and they've
got it
salaries and they've got this and that
you like okay the amount of money you're
raising isn't even get you to three
months it's not I'm gonna take you to
market the key right now in my mind is
invest in your future if you're doing it
with well a bunch of people take that
time and invest so yes do it right now
and I'll explain to you what what I
think you shouldn't do right
the point that I'm making here is don't
think about is making money right now
but laying the bricks
for your future now in terms of the fact
look ecommerce is hot everybody's trying
to get into it etc but it's also as
everybody's been getting into it over
the last few years
competition is up the markets saturated
you're not just gonna go in and make a
quick buck like you were able to five
years ago three years ago whatever and
the key to sustainability and longevity
is to lean in to what you're passionate
about you're gonna have more shitty days
then you're gonna have good dates or the
shitty days you're gonna feel more than
the good days so you gotta be passionate
about what you're doing what are you
actually passionate about in your life
and then figure out a way do I have the
ability to build a unique product and
take it to market or do I take something
that exists and make it better and take
it to market but again you've got to
love that [ __ ] thing you've got to
love that space you've got to think
about I mean the way I think about it is
like for me if I were to take a product
to market
it'd probably have something to do with
soccer because what I read when I'm not
reading about work whatever is I'm
following Arsenal Football Club fine
my point is like if I were to do that
that's what I would do because it's fun
and I enjoy it and I have a lot of depth
of knowledge in it so lean into that
sorry I'll go ahead it's it was a it's a
complicated question to answer you know
it is just know it can be a unique
product it could be a zoom and said
something remember Google was the 21st
search engine to come out in 1998 21st
and you know that they're
trillion-dollar market cap company so
you know you know yeah although I don't
think better saying this is necessarily
disruptive innovation you can have
incredible success and it doesn't have
to be the first product or something
that's super unique for following your
passion I think is good advice but you
have to have discipline and you do have
to invest in yourself first before you
can help others it's all about creating
value so it's the question was something
quick during the pandemic to make money
I don't know enough about the person
who's asking the question to give them
you know specific advice but add value
and the only way to do that is to again
invest in yourself and then understand
situational awareness is also important
understanding the holes that exist
around you and how you can fill that
with the skills and competencies you
that's always unique to you but I got to
tell you we've got to work hard you're
not no one's going to give you anything
and competition is fierce and talent
loses when they stop working hard so you
got to put in it's a ten-year commitment
to building something of success ten
years so there is no you know overnight
success usually for most takes many many
years of failure uncertainty rejection
hard work and if you don't have that
great persistence you're not gonna make
it
vallah this was brilliant thank you so
much for sharing your insight with us
and I'm gonna go back and watch us
myself because there's so much that you
put in there that I want to take notes
on honestly this was fantastic we are
intent with coffee and commerce is to
push the conversation forward about
commerce and I think we've certainly
done that today thank you so much for
your time well uh looking forward to
doing this again with you soon that
fantasy when I learned from you and Gary
and your team I can't wait to see the
trajectory of Commerce Vanna Commerce
and you know by the way of all the
things that Gary said about you through
your weekends made but drop the mic and
go celebrate yeah I know
I appreciate the best thanks brother Bob
I talk to you right